tél
[Musique]
les volo volo la branche est pas ma
chute me bigot est ce si beau renoncer à
ses mandats
bonjour à tous nous comptons ways of
gaga des cas première magazine zoo en
les 34e tourriol
non mais tu es chez toi martine
maintenant entre martiniquaise écoute je
fais mon mieux il faut dire qu'on est
ensemble tous les jours au coeur de
l'ambiance est au coeur de la coupe donc
forcément au cap à l'est et hall a tant
manqué brouillonne des coûts encore et
encore des 21 travailler mais c'est pas
mal
la 6e étape est parti ce matin du marin
pour arriver ici aux anses d'arlet au
programme de votre magazine
l'ambiance toujours aussi chaude les
résultats et les analyses de notre
spécialiste
et on commence tout de suite avec le
résumé de la course et c'est là les
supporters de rosette orange qui adultes
après six jours de course
le tenant du titre leur offre enfin une
première victoire d'étape mais c'était
loin d'être gagné
entre les hordes siders qui ont défié
les magpies est une promesse de mauvais
temps
pour cette 6e étape parcours inverse à
celui d'hier les embarcations quitte le
marin descente en vent arrière vers la
bouée de sainte-luce puis une deuxième
bouée à laisser à tribord avant de
couper la ligne d'arrivée pour départ
pour oser toros et tdm et zapetti
l'appaloosa l'ufr chant flore brasserie
lorraine respectivement première et
deuxième au classement général se marque
[Musique]
sur tania chaussures la présence sur le
plan d'eau aujourd'hui relève presque du
miracle
pas moins de huit hommes d'équipage dont
le patron ont quitté le tour du coup
c'est le président de l'association
olivier mérine qui tient la paillette
devant félix mérine a pris la direction
des opérations poursuivies par rosette
orange mais l'équipage n'est pas une
menace au classement général
contrairement à brasc et lorraine sahara
à seulement huit minutes marquées
caracoli ne suffira pas diagne et rémy
le set
il va tenter un incroyable coup c'est la
voile rouge et blanche sur votre écran
qui part chercher le vent du large
pendant que son rival est aux prises
avec la voile jeune da cau
une guerre robert francois qui profite
aux l'amandinois de cet été m
après un début de tour moyens l'équipage
semble avoir trouvé les bons réglages de
sa nouvelle embarcation hervier en tête
de course
pendant que brasserie lorraine sahara en
panne et amorce son retour vers la côte
stratégie audacieuse mais qui ne va rien
donner ufr chanflor au fond de l'écran
reste largement devant les maris droit
dans le reste de la flottille on
retrouve zapetti l'appaloosa gf a car
ali ben brik au bat not it ans est la
révélation du tour ait du vent
devant justement c'est tdm s'est
installé en tête de course et passe la
première la boue et de lancer rond suivi
de rosette orange ufr chanflor esso
marek
[Musique]
mais il va falloir tenir est passé le
rocher du diamant sous les reliefs les
hommes de petrik petiteau maîtrise comme
ils peuvent la voile qui subi des
rafales les bois dressés font preuve de
la plus grande vigilance au goût de
l'effort peut-être une première victoire
[Musique]
mais rosette orange a moins de
difficultés laguiole va bien les deux à
marie de la semaine ont titillé
l'orgueil des coursiers l' arme fatale
prend la tête de course en grand sage
félix mérine assist de loi la bataille
son adversaire à lui s'est dit annie
rémy et il est droit derrière plus
qu'une bouée à virer avant l'arrivée
c'était des iem tente d'anticiper son
virement de bord pour coiffer aco
mais c'est peine perdue rosette orange
sauf son honneur sur ce tour 2010 8
gf à troisième a profité de l'engagement
plus modérée de félix mérine mais les
roberton conservent leur maillot rouge
[Musique]
rosette orange remporte l'étape sa
première sur ce tour déception pour cet
été mdf qui a cru jusqu'au bout mais
finit deuxième à 23 secondes seulement
ça passe cette fois ci pour gfk caraïbes
troisième ufr chanflor est quatrième ce
homard est petit navire 5e zapetti la
panoz a fini neuvième
à 16 minutes et 3 secondes
monsieur bricolage smartphone services
plus et 11e hôtel brise marine lipton
ice tea boucherie prudent 12e 10 h 10
quand ferme la marche a pris d'une heure
43 minutes et 7 secondes
l'ufr chanteur n'aura jamais perdu son
maillot rouge une fois acquis et voit
son seul adversaire brasserie lorraine
sarah s'éloigner à 16 minutes et 28
secondes se marre est petit navire à
1h13 conforte sa troisième place
l'écart avec un nouveau passe de 22
secondes hier à huit minutes aujourd'hui
suivent gf et un pisteur rosette/orange
zapetti est 9e à 2h45 royal fruit de
martinique adeptes qui est distant
espace santé optical center et tania
chaussures smsr termine le classement la
dernière yole accuse un retard de 10
heures et 33 minutes
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ban
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
pour wayne et on va danser avec les
supporters
[Applaudissements]
ses partenaires
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
on sentait koala un choix ajoie deuxième
étape hier il n'avait pas de chance
aujourd'hui c'est un lieu où tout est à
faire
ils sont
les olives 4e
[Musique]
saint-etienne qui est génial quand comme
moi on n'a pas de yacht préféré moi je
les aime tous ses copains derrière tout
est fait avec toutes les équipes il
savait comment dit on n'a pas eu de
chance ou cette édition sera tout mais
au moins une victoire d'étape on ne peut
pas nous l'enlever plaisir avec plaisir
[Applaudissements]
le drame
c'est fou
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
attendez attendez attendez attendez
attendez j'ai pas très bien entendu
qu'ils n'ont rien là qui nous ya la
viola
qui n'ont rien
imola il miaule ils vont y aller
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
mia bruyère quelle ambiance hétéro date
qui remporte l'étape du jour c'était
dingue
et oui rosette voulait gagner car et
hier ils ont fini loin ils ont coulé
alors qu'est-ce qui a fait la différence
les réponses avec les patrons eux mêmes
c'est à dire en libye
[Musique]
on a joué de malchance
aujourd'hui on voulait à tout prix
gagner pour nos supporters ils sont
restés d'ailleurs nous attendent
hélas cette victoire c'est poule est
alors pour demain qu'est ce que qu'est
ce que vous prévoyez justement pour
cette prochaine étape
bon c'est vrai pour nous on a perdu le
tour alors on va essayer de jouer la
victoire la victoire d'eva essaie de
jouer la victoire avec toi de ta
déception même parce que là la première
place était quand même à portée de main
le vent se lève et puis les bateaux
suiveurs nous ont beaucoup gênés à ne
l'a pas des fous n'occuper qu'un aux
études puis action nous dépasse mais on
est quand même satisfait de cette
deuxième place pour déjà nous consoler
des bois 10 ans ou encore le moment
aussi embauché des leaders et puis pour
nos supporters qui nous supportent tous
les jours même dans la déveine on est
sur la même dynamique là le groupe a
fait un super boulot attention
voilà on continue à mascate on travaille
toujours on croit toujours un nom et
bains jusqu'au dernier jour jusqu'au
dernier jour on va continuer on va se
battre pour remonter au classement
aujourd'hui on voulait arriver si avant
le bois si l'objectif était de contrôler
pas de gagner parce que ça ça sert à
rien et aujourd'hui il fallait aller
fait de mon bras si ça le fait moi j'ai
pas fini c'est pas fini le sol tout
comme cet homme voit si on est costaud
tient qu'aux voyages au jury à brossard
savage angola l'année des neiges à
cossette possède à gagner cette année à
boissy bassila voyez quand même bravo à
jojo on a tendance à l'air à ne pas
parler de lui parce que là aussi c'est
beau temps heureusement pour les bourses
est passée sans fatigue est bien arrivé
ici on plaisante troisième place et
c'est mon plus gros jam qui avait été en
mer ont vu ils mettraient des mots qui a
déjà coaché de baisser mais bon j'étais
pas trop d'accord mais bon on a mieux le
fonctionnement en place respectent et
ils vont en avoir le vent on respecte
leur choix mais c'est le tube poker
parce que la banque avait annoncé
beaucoup de voir et ça s'est pas produit
mais c'est la nature que vous lui
madonna des communes genevoises beau oui
aux quotas qui même s'ils ont perdu ce
match ça allait pas golf parce qu'on ne
voulait pas coulée dans la descente
savoir de ce nouveau le vent a baissé
parce qu'ils ont des plus grands
c'était l'objectif c'est à dire arriver
ici à abobo
[Musique]
google
sans ces bonnes odeurs qui nous entoure
la jemmerais j'arrive pas à cibler ce
que c'est une façon un peu le poulet
grillé il ya quelque chose de délicieux
qui se prépare moi j'ai un petit creux
la qui montre la l'appétit franchement
le william le tour des yoles c'est aussi
pour moi qui suis de passage sur l'île
l'occasion de découvrir les spécialités
locales et pour moi c'est l'occasion
mais vraiment des petits plats de manger
les petits plats qui sent bon les
vacances comme le lambi grillé on vous
propose ce titre de vous régaler avec
notre séquence coulisses dans quatre
premières ceylan braafheid du jour
[Musique]
visiter la côte cassée la langue et vous
avez un petit secret pour la faire celle
ci la pole distance et l'alambic cette
année tout ça c'est vraiment les
brochettes de l'envié on avait aussi du
prix cassés de l'andi plus qu'assez de
jacou c'est un plat qui a énormément de
succès ici le lobby beaucoup de succès
en dessous des yeux louis prévient le
poulet grillé à briller le poisson
grillé les rites surtout et puis prendre
côtes de porc et un trois contre
chez free du qu'abrite avec des frites
un mélangeur particulier c'est plutôt
mais plein de choix sur le tour vous
aurez pu manger des crêpes des burgers
des paninis mais vous faut pas déconner
tu vois c'est le cas d'ailleurs c'est
local il faut acheter local
c'est pas mal en pis le lambi est
implantée à l'envi de chez nous choisis
du lobby
je voyais ma vie en noir moi j'ai l'on
crève bon fait la promotion de notre
pays nous sommes fiers d'eux tandis
qu'en face à man ou s'il vous plaît de
l'avis de la banque
c'est pas la même chose que l'on a envie
voilà le vrai l'auditoire ça me fait
plaisir j'aime ça j'aime bien faire leur
part ça occupe avec arnaud toujours chez
lui
[Musique]
j'ai choisi jury avec des dribbles et
puis c'est pas toujours en plus des fois
comme de pau en faire autre chose que
justin que du poulet
bon je suis une fan de quoi sont donc
s'il a de quoi s'ennuyer sur mon mieux
mais tout ce qui est fou de meilleur je
saute sur l'occasion en fait
avant je faisais ça j'espère surtout
mais maintenant j'ai dit non parce qu'il
ya trop de friture de machin enfin on
arrive et on peut le détruire tout
laissait rien que du vrai j entreprends
l'âge ça va pas là je peux faire local
désormais on va tous de venir manger
chez vous comme vous voulez vous allons
trouver et satinée fouilles après
j'aurais mangé du lobby je suis en
vacances je profite pour nous sur good
complet pour pouvoir toucher un maximum
de public et puis pour pouvoir vraiment
vraiment se relâcher en même temps donc
on allie les deux gars nous ont bien
commander les brochettes de l'omi alors
on vient de bretagne on connaît pas du
tout entendu parler on nous a dit que
c'était très bon donc on vient d'acheter
pour manger au goûter en bretagne on
nous en parle depuis que tout le monde
sait combien ici en martinique tout le
monde nous en parle tout le monde il
faut absolument goûter
il faut manger local et c'est important
de faire vivre nos restaurateurs
ambulants qui viennent sur le tour des
yoles pour vendre leurs marchandises et
puis ça fait travailler aussi les
agriculteurs disent qu'on est cool dans
produit je trouve que les martiniquais
prennent du poids il fallait il fallait
qu'il se pose les bonnes questions et
d'essayer de manger un peu plus locales
et de mettre de côté les hamburgers les
filets des campagnes et on sait ça fait
grossir non moins charmant avec ça
[Musique]
t
bonjour madame
ah non je passais à côté de places
libres
vous êtes vraiment la vraie supportrice
oui ça pète est ce que vous êtes déjà
montés à bord d'une yole et bien sûr
monsieur quelles sensations ça vous
avait conquise et à bourg d'izon j'ai
toujours peur de l'ailleurs ah bon ah
oui j'ai toujours peur ça ça je
chérissais de coeur si mais je n'arrive
pas c'est un connaisseur le voilà donc
je préfère être sur le sable à
tranquille dis-moi loïc duba qu on
essaie est ce que tu as déjà essayé tata
le corps pour faire de laguiole oui j'en
ai bien fait deux éditions c'est vrai
charles et et ses boîtes assez compliqué
c'est alors quelles sensations on a
comme ça quand on est sur le bateau sur
le bois dressés
c'est une très bonne sensation mais vite
fatigant parce que
vont-ils sortir les houles et vac c'est
parti mon goût de vous
je veux bien te croire j'ai beaucoup
d'admiration williams a dû constater que
les supporters savent ce qui se passe en
mer pour les coursiers connaît ses
sensations ce sont vraiment des
connaisseurs tiga et d'ailleurs pour est
ce que tu as déjà ressentir les
sensations à bord d'une yole j'ai eu
cette chance il ya quelques années j'ai
essayé et ce qui me reste c'est vraiment
une impression de liberté extrême
j'avais adoré mais c'était vraiment pour
essayer c'était la curiosité pour les
conseillers c'est tout autre chose
eux ils sont vraiment en mode
compétition ils vont au bout d'eux mêmes
on vous propose d'aller au plus près de
l'équipage ait souvent aujourd'hui de
sainte anne
ils n'ont pas de sponsors mais ils ont
du coeur exactement
grâce à notre caméra embarquée découvrez
comment ils ont vécu l'étape d'hier
c'est notre séquence en ciel à la
boutique n'a manqué le plus c'est au
niveau du rocher du diamant
parce que la lgv a aussi et on a du
décès laguiole à temps et au bon moment
on avait des yeux moi d'abord favorable
qu'on puisse rattraper certaines yole
[Musique]
la 3ds était de passer sans casse
décidée face et l'embauché et puis après
j'ai la pousse parce que la grande
difficulté c'est au creux du rocher
c'est un peu délicat mme despatie débat
si hot docs
on a pu quand même gérer chose faite la
carte sim carey nous a aidés on n'a pas
de compenser pour la porter
[Musique]
non
c'est quand même fou au sens après ça
elle a été parfaite juste pour le temps
on a ressenti un moment de soulagement
on se force un petit peu moins ce qu on
a passé le rocher la lgv on est un petit
peu plus régulier on avait plus de
google
on a vu que c'est passé on n'a pas trop
fait les fronts radio et je suis fier de
ça
ça va la vie pour toi quand tu tombes
bien william est ce que tu pourrais
mettre de la crème solaire dans le dos
il te plait carrément mais si c'est bien
parce que c'est toi et parce que le
soleil est chaud exactement
et d'ailleurs quel que soit votre
carnation il faut se protéger du soleil
est ce que tu sais quelle est la
différence entre l' indice 10 20 30 50
c'est une histoire de l'espace entre
l'application je crois exactement si
vous mettez un indice vous serez protégé
10 minutes si vous mettez un indice à
quand vous serez protégé donc 50 minutes
donc si j'ai un conseil à vous donner
allez directement avec vers lundi 50 et
vous serez protégé voilà manière très
pointue en la matière mais les tue
autant en matière de viol un petit peu
moins c'est vrai ça tombe bien place à
notre rubrique technique yole chaque
jour on décrypte un élément aujourd'hui
ce sont les écoutes en créant dit la
reine l'aréna au la reine en bas c'est
ce qui permet de régler la voile
technique yonne
[Musique]
les écoutes sont réalisés avec du
cordage des poulies découpe du bas de la
voile mesure près de 50 mètres alors que
celles dues aux mesures va mettre les
deux pèse 12 kg au total
[Musique]
avant il y avait une seule écoute qui
reliait le haut et le bas de la voile
il fallait au moins trois personnes pour
régler la voilure comme sur ces images
des années 90
[Musique]
aujourd'hui une ou deux personnes
suffisent car les écoutes sont séparés
et le palan facilite les manoeuvres
le pas lent est un cordage avec une pour
y fixer sur la voile et une autre pour y
fixer sur la yole un taquets coinceurs
permet de bloquer la voile au réglage
voulu enfin un cordage relie la tête de
la voile c'est l'écoutent duo
[Musique]
les écoutes ont une durée de vie de
seulement deux ans car elles sont
soumises à de fortes tensions
le cordage résiste à une tonne de charge
elle coûte 2000 à 1500 euros leur
fonction est de régler la voix les
écoutes permettent de régler la voile
pour une compulsion optimale plus le
vent vient de l'arrière plus il faut
choquer les écoutes
c'est à dire donner du mou pour relâcher
la voie en créole ont dit qu'ils ne
veulent plus le voir vient de phase plus
il faut border les échos c'est à dire
tirer sur les cordages
en cas de fortes rafales le manoeuvre
des coudes doit choquer très rapidement
pour relâcher de la tension dans la
voile sinon c'est la barre il ya
milliards on a assisté à une étape très
ensoleillé aujourd'hui il y avait un peu
de pluie
donc c'était plus compliqué pour les
copies si oui qui dit grain divan il y
avait aussi un peu de mer agitée donc
les conseils ont dû gérer ça ça mérite
l'analyse de notre spécialiste maison
jean trudeau qu'est-ce qui a fait la
différence aujourd'hui et qu'est ce qui
attend les conseillers demain 4shared
apple jean trudeau à vous la parole
[Musique]
la vie est un long fleuve tranquille
c'est ce qu'ont dû se dire ceux qui ont
regardé la cause parce qu'on avait
l'impression que rien ne se passait pas
les équipages parce que sur les lieux
avec le vent de derrière les organismes
sollicités
il devait faire très attention pour la
stabilité de laguiole et puis pour
continuer au fait ce qui a donné cette
émission il y avait 2 cos une course
pour ceux qui allaient à la gagne qui
voulait arriver les premiers aux anses
d'arlet à ce petit jeu aux et orange il
a mystifié cdtm et df du côté du monde
jacqueline et puis il y avait une autre
cause ou ceux qui souhaitent contrôler
et bien là ufr chanflor a remisé
brasserie lorraine sarah énergies
nouvelles à 16 minutes et puis les
autres sont arrivés dans à peu près -
2h02 mais vous allez me dire que j'ai
dit je joue demain ce sera difficile oui
ce sera difficile parce qu'il faut
sortir des en harley pour arriver à fort
de france pointe des zones de calme il y
aura un peu de tout mais des rafales qui
viennent de la terre y aura des bords at
il y aura des empannages à faire tout
ceci pour arriver en grand vainqueur sur
la plage de la française alors mon petit
doigt que je consulte tous les jours ne
m'a rien dit j'ai tâché avec la boule de
cristal je n'ai toujours pas de raison
[Musique]
william demain nous allons assister à la
7e étape
septième étape qui partira d'ici les
anses d'arlet pour aller à fort de
france il y aura encore des difficultés
pour tous les équipages et notamment
pour l'équipage de zita bonne chance à
tous voici le profil de l'étape de
demain
[Musique]
6e étape marc est installé départ à 10
heures de la plage du bourg du marel
voile filet direction la pointe
bohémienne un empannage de voile à la
pointe borghèse pour aller en direction
de la marque numéro un est situé face à
l'inspiron il faut passer entre la
marque numéro un la terre là les voiles
son fils et si le vin et haisnes horde
est dominant on est au vent arrière avec
beaucoup de manoeuvres beaucoup de
stabilité de laguiole à établir
direction cette fameuse pointe de
diamant pour la laisser sur tribord
passé entre la terre et le rocher du
diamant aborder nos habituels difficulté
du côté de la fasse défaut du côté du
monde jacqueline ses rafales qui
viennent de la terre qui viennent de
petites installer des anses d'arlet on
va aussi abordé les rafales qui viennent
de l'anchois d'hyères pour aller virer
cette marque numéro 2 a laissé sur
tribord où aller couper la ligne
d'arrivée constitué de deux bouées
mouillées devant la plage du bourg des
han sol
[Musique]
baby le monde
quatre premières votre magazine
quotidien consacré au tour de la
martinique des yoles rondes c'est
terminé pour aujourd'hui demain la 7e
étape partira d'ici aux anses d'arlet
pour arriver à fort de france le chef
lieu c'est sûr l'ambiance sera très très
chaude venez soutenir les yoleurs metiga
c'est déjà l'avant dernière étape
et oui c'est vrai williams s'est passé
tellement vite cela dit c'est pour cela
qu'il ne faut pas la manquer les courses
et comptent sur nous et nous on compte
sur vous à retrouver nous à 20 heures
comme tous les jours sur martinique 1ère
et à 7h35 pour les lève tôt sur france ô
qu'est ce qu'on dit luca roy thomas
mokawloo
[Applaudissements]
m
enfin
[Musique]
on joue au chat et à la souris